hello my name is joe ellis i studied
science at school my question to you is
as a Nobel laureate how would you
enthused and inspire the next generation
of scientists who are going to inherit
the earth in the 21st century well hi
Joe I think every child in our entire
planet needs to hear this story of how
we think we came to be here and what our
challenges are going to be in the near
term every child should be exposed to
the beauty of the sky every child should
hear about the the nature of life and
how we're made of atoms and where the
atoms came from from exploded stars and
how we're beginning to understand how
the earth functions and how the weather
changes and how we're changing the
climate and using up the resources of
the world as we go because this is
obviously a very important technical
problem as well as an international
political question our children do
inherit the earth and they can get the
job to manage the garden so we need to
help them understand that they can do it
and that there are things that they can
learn in school that will help them do
it we also have to show them how
beautiful it is and how exciting it is
to work on these wonderful questions so
we're at the key we're at the center of
planning for our future life here on
planet earth and I think it's a
wonderful story to tell people I think
children can appreciate it very
beautifully if we tell them